[Music]
moving on our main story tonight
concerns police interrogations you're
probably familiar with them as they're a
staple of countless tv shows including
ones you might not expect
did you kill your father with this axe
no i didn't lie to me again and i'll
arrest you for murder capisce honey i'd
like a mineral water no ice
and i'd like your balls in a blender but
ain't like a [ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
pinkie pie's about to [ __ ] that dragon
up
i was not expecting a clip from my
little pony to look like a deleted scene
from training day but you can see why
interrogation scenes are so popular on
tv they're inherently dramatic and can
result in a confession moving the story
along but it's not just audiences who
find them compelling juries do too
confessions are viewed as the gold
standard when it comes to an indicator
of guilt as they can apparently be more
persuasive than even dna evidence just
listen to all these jurors in high
profile trials explain the key evidence
that convinced them to convict we just
felt that no one would confess three
times
if they didn't do it he could have
continued to deny it if you did not hurt
that baby i mean you would go to your
grave saying no i didn't it was very
hard to imagine why anybody would make
up something that not only incriminates
them but have is full of details
that
sound like they actually happened
yeah confessions are wildly persuasive
because we think that they're one of
those things that only guilty people do
you know like a posting a notes app
apology or refusing to answer any of
ronan farrow's questions but here is the
thing in all those jurors cases the
confession later turned out to be false
that last juror was from the case of the
central park five was the now known the
exonerated five in fact of all the
convictions that have been overturned
through dna testing 29
involved false confessions and you may
find that hard to believe because it can
be very hard to comprehend how someone
could confess to something they didn't
do just watch lester holt struggle to
get his head around it while talking to
a journalist who covered a false
confession case the more i investigated
it the more i came to believe that he
might be telling me the truth
there is not a shred of forensic or
physical evidence but he confessed yeah
like most people you can't possibly
fathom admitting you did something that
you didn't do nobody does that nobody
would think they're capable of doing it
but the truth is a skilled interrogator
could probably get uri to admit we
kidnapped the lindbergh baby
exactly honestly a skilled interrogator
could probably even get me to admit that
i am the lindbergh baby it does kind of
make sense considering that this body
type is a physique best described as 92
year old dead baby
the truth is there are a number of
reasons an innocent person might confess
to something they didn't do and a lot of
that comes down to what happens in a
police interrogation room so tonight
let's talk about police interrogations
what tactics they use and how damaging
they can be particularly for the
innocent and let's start with some
history here because it used to be
police could basically torture people to
get confessions a practice that came to
be known as using the third degree but
in 1936 the supreme court declared
physical coercion unconstitutional
meaning that police departments had to
adopt new techniques and it says
something that their early attempts to
do this feature some pretty basic
instructions like in this film from the
texas department of public safety
look the suspect in the eyes to observe
eye movements and physical changes that
might indicate deception
if you can't look him in the eyes watch
an imaginary x on the forehead or knows
it's the same effect
once deception is detected you know
you're on the right track
okay hold on
was drawing the x really necessary there
were they genuinely worried their
officers wouldn't know how to look at a
forehead without visual representation
because if they cannot spot a forehead
i'd argue maybe they should not be
trusted to spot a criminal
but eventually one particular approach
became the standard the read technique
named after one of its creators john e
reed a former chicago police officer
turned polygraph expert he formed a
training firm that now claims to have
trained hundreds of thousands of
investigators and has influenced nearly
every aspect of modern police
interrogations the read techniques
become one of those things that just
culturally comes with being a cop you
know like they're fondest for donuts or
their complicity in the perpetuation of
state-sponsored violence
and when it comes to questioning
suspects there are two major phases to
the read technique the interview where
you determine whether someone is a
suspect and the interrogation where you
try to get them to confess now in the
interview stage the goal is to gauge how
truthful the answers you're getting are
the approach is similar to a lie
detector test you essentially start with
some basic questions to set a baseline
then move to so-called behavior
provoking questions when you analyze the
suspect's verbal and crucially
non-verbal behavior this retraining film
for instance explains how barrier
postures like crossing your arms are a
sign that you're lying
the next two illustrations we're going
to see
each subject moves into a barrier
posture after they were asked the
critical question
why do you think bob said he saw you
selling marijuana
hey come on how should i know i mean who
who knows why people say things i sure
don't
mark
have you ever thought about sexually
touching a child
no
not seriously
now hold on first let's acknowledge
those are clearly community theater
actors trying their hardest to convey
guilt
and we should give the first actress her
flowers because she showed up to that
non-union gig ready to work
as for this guy he's doing a pretty spot
on kevin spacey impression there between
the facial resemblance the haircut and
the unconvincing denials of sexual
attraction to children he's really
nailing it
and i know that that looks dated but
it's still very much in use that video
is available for purchase right now on
reed's website it was 100
and it was not remotely worth it but
there is a big issue with relying on
that sort of behavioral analysis because
while reid claims that investigators
trained in their technique have shown an
average accuracy of 83
in identifying deceptive subjects the
truth is much less impressive as this
retired homicide investigator explains
the read people admit that it's not
based on any science whatsoever just
based on their own observations
the real science says
it's baloney it doesn't work
um and it
when they've done experiments with it
they pretty much show
that the accuracy is like flipping a
coin
it's 50 50.
right it's basically chance it's got
around the same accuracy as a buzzfeed
quiz answer 17 questions about peter and
we'll tell you which gilmore girl you
are
wait i'm a rory the [ __ ] are you talking
about buzzfeed i'm a lorelei all day i
talk fast i carry the weight of the
world on my shoulders and god do i look
good in a pea coat
and i have to tell you reed and
associates will insist that their
interview technique is part of an
overall approach that works if you just
follow all of the instructions in their
400th page manual to the letter but this
thing is so full of caveats and outright
contradictions you can find support in
it for nearly any conclusion that you
want to reach for instance when it comes
to eye contact it advises that when a
person is being less than honest he may
not maintain direct eye contact but also
others may over compensate by staring
meaning if you have eyes you're
basically [ __ ] and i'm not saying that
reed is the only problem here there's
now a whole industry of consultants who
supposedly train cops to spot liars but
it's all [ __ ]
years of research has demonstrated that
behavioral cues like eye blinking and
arm crossing are simply not reliable
indicators of deception which does make
sense people move their bodies in all
sorts of ways whether they are telling
the truth or not in fact the only truly
honest body movement that humans are
capable of is when someone accidentally
walks through a spider web that's it
then and only then are your gestures
completely truthful
and void of presence of [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
thanks to this junk science police can
essentially assure themselves of their
own certainties and if they have decided
you are guilty you're in big trouble
because that is when the interrogation
begins and while they'll say that they
are looking for the truth read trains
officers to steer the conversation away
from anything that's not a confession
many guilty people introduce their
denials with permission phrases such as
can i say one thing would you just
listen to me but sir if i could only
explain
when the interrogator hears those
phrases it's important to interject
yourself and stop the person from
continuing because if you let him talk
he'll say the words i didn't do it
and the more often a person says they
didn't do it
the more difficult it becomes for us to
get a confession
oh yes the telltale signs of guilt would
you please listen to me can i explain
and i'm telling you i didn't do it
and if an investigator is trying to get
you to confess they can grind you down
interrogations can last from a couple of
hours to double digits one study of
false confessions found that they came
after an average of 16.3 hours of
questioning which can be utterly
exhausting innocent people can wind up
confessing just to escape the stress of
that situation that was the case with
robert davis who at just 18 was
suspected of double murder and
interrogated for over five hours
what can i say that i did to get me out
of this people like go home
huh when will i go home today
like a whole town i can't promise you
look when you work with me i'm do
everything i can to make sure your mom
and we can get you maybe get you home
robert i'm gonna come straight out and
tell you what i was what what i'm
getting
all right since you're not gonna tell me
you stabbed that woman
you stabbed her didn't you
one or two times what do you think about
me telling you this is going to be
yeah he lied about stabbing someone then
immediately admitted that he lied but by
that point it was too late he actually
went to prison for 13 years before being
exonerated the notion that people crack
under pressure and falsely confess
really shouldn't be that hard to
understand it's a concept that even
children's cartoons get because remember
that my little pony scene from earlier
this is how it continued
no no no no
what do you want to hear tell me what
you want me to see and i'll see it tell
me what you want me to say and i'll say
it i kidnap the lindbergh baby is that
what you want to hear your pink psycho
and the thing is people might assume
that even if they falsely confess they
can later recant and the real evidence
will prevail and clear them but that's
actually very unlikely because as soon
as the police get a confession thorough
investigations tend to stop and at this
point i'm going to answer the question
that you may have had for a while now
why don't people just invoke their
constitutional right to an attorney well
the truth is approximately 80 percent
waive their miranda rights and willingly
submit to a police interrogation for a
number of understandable reasons
sometimes people think i don't need a
lawyer i didn't do anything or they
believe they're only being brought in as
a witness and not a suspect but not
having a lawyer makes you incredibly
vulnerable because for one thing a
lawyer might clue you into an absolutely
insane power that police in america have
been given by the supreme court in the
united states a detective can legally
lie about the evidence to a suspect it
is lawful for detectives to turn to a
suspect and say you say you didn't do
this but we've got your fingerprints on
the murder weapon or we have a victim
who had hair in her grasp and we tested
the hair it's yours
or the shoe prints we found at the scene
are yours or that polygraph you wanted
to take you failed it
it's true the police in this country can
flat out lie to you to make you think
you have no choice but to confess and
some of the lies they tell are simply
ridiculous an investigator in florida
told the suspect they had a laser the
kind that you shoot on star wars and
with it they can actually lift
fingerprints off bodies a technology
that to be clear does not exist
although having said that i'm now pretty
sure that we're just one bad pitch
meeting away from the star wars laser
getting its own 10 episode series on
disney plus the laser will be voiced by
oscar isaac and we'll all come
now
allowing the police to lie to suspects
is crazy
most countries do not allow it and for
good reason it is far too powerful a
tool remember robert davis it might
still be hard for you to imagine why he
confessed to doing something that he
didn't do
but look at what the interrogator was
claiming in that room
i can't even have to ask dust is made of
most of some human dead skin
that can be picked up that's dna i'm not
going to keep you from the worst robert
if you don't talk to me i can't keep you
from the word
ronnie you were you were there that
evidence shows you were there
that shows i can't lie about the
evidence
i can't lie about the evidence he lied
as he lied about the evidence and did it
gesturing with all the theatrical nuance
of a high schooler auditioning for a few
good men
the overwhelming pressure of a police
interrogation coupled with their ability
to invent evidence can actually make
people question their own memories that
happened with christopher tapp who
served 20 years in prison for a murder
he did not commit and was heavily
manipulated during his interrogation
i wasn't there
wait i think you sounded to me like i
was there the police told me a few times
if there was something that horrific you
would definitely hide it and it'd go in
your subconscious
it's just like me
some of the little stuff that we see out
on the streets my mind shuts down on me
because i don't want to remember
i started second guessing myself during
all this i started to not believe in
myself or who i was i don't know because
right now everything i've been saying
what i think is right in my head has
been wrong
that is terrible and it is more than a
little infuriating how that investigator
convinces him of doubting his own memory
by making it seem like it happens all
the time you half expect him to say you
know how you can't remember if it was
the berenstein bears or berenstain bears
or if shaq was in a movie called shazam
or maybe it was simbad and the movie was
actually called kazam that's what your
brain's doing right now but with murder
brains are weird huh
all these tactics are incredibly
manipulative and they work especially
well on certain people research shows
false confessions were a factor in 34
of cases in which children were wrongly
convicted and a stunning 69 of cases in
which people with mental illness or
intellectual disabilities were later
exonerated and look
there are some limits on what police can
do some judges won't allow a confession
if the police promised you leniency in
exchange for it but many cops walk right
up to that line by suggesting a
confession might reduce prison time or
spare you the death penalty you just saw
that happen with robert davis when that
officer told him he could keep him from
the worse also
police are told not to feed you
information about the crime that is not
publicly available as it's obviously
damning for a jury to hear that you knew
details only the guilty party would know
but that happens all the time too one
study of dna exonerations found that 94
of false confessions were contaminated
by allegedly inside information and the
thing is
even if police engage in these tactics
crucially the jury may only see the
confession not the interrogation that
led up to it only 30 states require the
recording of interrogations at all and
in the rest it's up to the police who
might only record the confession that's
it
and you just cannot get the full story
from seeing one short clip imagine if
the only clip that you'd ever seen in
the show one tree hill was
to the this
dr passport
[Applause]
nurse henderson
[Music]
do you want to know what one tree hill
is about it's about a high school
basketball team you'd have no way of
knowing that from that clip all you
would know is that it contained the most
perfect 20 seconds of television that
has ever existed
the problem with police interrogations
right now is the same problem that we
have with policing at large they're
emboldened to act however they'd like in
a system where they hold an undue amount
of power with very few protections for
civilians especially the most vulnerable
because there can be little to no
consequences for extracting a false
confession just listen to this man who
was a 19 year old former special
education student at the time of his
arrest for raping and murdering a woman
after being interrogated over the course
of four days including fun fact two
polygraphs conducted by reading
associates he confessed under pressure
and spent nearly 20 years in prison
until finally being exonerated by dna
all the officers
that worked in my case as well as
state's attorneys they've all retired
with pension
full pension there was no repercussion
no retribution no criminal charges
nothing
they actually exceeded in their job
they retired as captains majors
lieutenants the headstays attorney
michael waller retired and they gave him
a plaque for a good job
that is maddening that state attorney
certainly doesn't deserve a good job
plaque unless it came with another
drop-down plaque that read at [ __ ] up
innocent people's lives you monumental
[ __ ]
and what i've spent tonight showing you
people who were exonerated there are
still many incarcerated people fighting
convictions that have every hallmark of
a false confession like brendan dassey
from making a murderer who was 16 when
he confessed to a murder that he could
not describe and melissa lucio whose
incredibly manipulative interrogation we
featured in our wrongful convictions
piece and it was set to be executed in
just 10 days so what can we do well we
should absolutely require all
interrogations to be recorded in their
entirety so juries have the full context
of what happened in that room we should
also make it illegal for police to lie
to suspects because it is madness that
they are currently allowed to do that
and there's actually a growing movement
for some reform here these three states
have now banned police from lying to
juvenile suspects and new york has
introduced legislation that would ban
lying to all suspects and require courts
to evaluate the reliability of
confession evidence before allowing it
to be used and that should be adopted
absolutely everywhere and if you think
you will hold on john how will
investigators get guilty people to
confess if they can't intimidate or lie
to them well not to be a total [ __ ] but
their job is literally to investigate so
maybe they could try doing some of that
also you can productively interrogate
someone without lying to them the uk now
uses something called the peace method
where they ask open-ended questions and
let the suspect give their own account
and i am not saying that that system is
perfect it clearly isn't among other
things they still haven't gotten the
queen to confess to killing diana on
camera but it's at least a start and in
the meantime there's actually a lot of
cultural conditioning regarding police
interrogations that we need to start
undoing because think about it how many
dramas have you seen on tv where
roughing up the bad guy led to solving
the crime how many shows have there been
where the bad guy seemed guilty and the
officer's gut feeling was confirmed by
the end of the episode our
misconceptions about police
interrogations have been hammered in by
crime dramas and they've been hammered
in deep and perhaps one small way to
help undo that damage is for shows to
present a slightly more accurate picture
of what can really happen in that room
this fall
meet two tough cops
expert interrogators
knock knock who won't take no for an
answer
you son of a [ __ ] you're guilty you
dirty rat bastard what are you talking
about you know what we're talking about
the murder in the alley i didn't do no
no no no
i can't hear that we cannot hear you say
that
they're highly trained you're lying no
i'm not oh you looked away that is lying
now you're staring that's lying too
more lies
and incredibly skilled what are you
doing making eye contact no you're not
yes i am
are you looking at my forehead no
and they'll say anything to get what
they need have you seen rogue one the
star wars movie that star wars film
i think i saw it once yeah you're
probably familiar with lightsabers
probably less familiar with the fact
that we have them and they have the
ability to pull dna from a dead body
with a single
i cannot lie about this it's true he
can't lie about the wrong
and i mean anything you ever get to work
and not remember any of your commute
maybe it was like that it was murder is
this dress black and blue or gold and
white you've got two choices confess to
one count of murder two or two counts of
murder one you gotta help us help you
help us help you help us convict you
murderer says what
what well that counts that counts
oh no are you allergic to your own
victim did you spoil a dead body on me
did you just blow it dead body on me yes
yeah i got evidence coming out of every
hole of my body those can't be aliens
those can't be the only choice
guys
it's been 15 and a half hours
i can't take much more of this
well you know if you help me out a
little bit maybe i can make sure that
you get to sleep in your own bed tonight
fine
i did it
yes
ace in the hole baby
sorry about the delay fellas here's your
perp we don't need any more suspects the
one you brought us yesterday just
confessed
but this was the guy you're supposed to
interrogate yesterday
who the hell is this
i just came in here to charge my phone
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you're still going to jail
put them in the cups
[Laughter]
hey don't forget your phone
[Applause]
i'm gonna fist
the confestigators
hey it ain't ruining my life
you